hey guys it's max for max tech and this
is Noah and what is this daddy yes and
how much does it cost five hundred
dollars so this is Noah's first computer
it's a five hundred dollar budget gaming
PC that we designed to be able to play
games like for night at 1080p on high
settings with at least 60 frames per
second so that was the goal here you
guys will see if we achieve that goal
and the whole point was to be able to
build something together and no one I
actually put it together and instruct
him how to do it he did a majority of it
and we actually made a step by step
build guide so if you guys want to see
how you can build this PC step by step
super easy even if you've never built
one before you guys can subscribe to the
channel neighborhood occasions we'll be
posting that video soon and along with
that we have all of the parts that we
use listed down in the description along
with some alternatives because parts do
change there are some things that may be
able to better choice and all of that is
gonna be linked down below and now since
both myself and know we have to kind of
get better at 49 we're gonna hand this
off to Vadim and he's gonna put us
through its paces and see how it
performs and give you guys some
entertainment footage to take a look at
all right buddy take it away so Before
we jump into some Fortnight gameplay I
want to first mention that this display
right here is not a budget monitor it's
actually a 4k IPS monitor from LG now if
you're also shopping around for a budget
monitor we actually made a video
comparing four of the best budget gaming
monitors in 2018 and we actually found a
clear winner so you should definitely
check out that video after this video is
over we'll leave a button to it at the
very end alright so here we are in the
four nice settings I've set it to full
screen 1080p unlimited frame rate
everything's on Epic as you guys can see
even the shadows aren't epic which
sometimes people turn those down well
we're gonna try everything completely
maxed out all right here we are in game
and it looks like we're hovering around
60 FPS yeah look at that
75 right now it's actually pretty good
almost got that guy
whoa gotcha whoa
make sure nobody's around me so far I'm
really impressed we're sticking out
around 70 even higher than 70 FPS so
what is this thing go bro what's up
that's just fun oh so close
did you guys see that here we are in the
settings shadow is off apply whoa would
you look at that we're above a hundred
FPS right here that is a massive
difference that's like 30 to 40 FPS
higher just returning the shadows off
and in reality do you really need the
shadows I don't know but I can say that
you're getting so much more FPS I don't
think we're gonna go below 60 here at
all oh I just got that dude do you see
that all right I gotta get misty now oh
man there's no somebody else got him
what no oh now are you he sniping from
like over there so far I'm really
surprised that we're actually getting
over a hundred FPS on this five hundred
dollar gaming build I've got to say this
is probably the best budget gaming PC
build you can make in 2018 hands down so
if you were to buy a gaming monitor
that's a hundred forty-four Hertz you
could actually do this same build but
upgrade the graphics card I think the
Radeon rx 580 will actually be perfect
to get 144 Hertz at these settings epic
everything which shadows off I think
that'll actually be a perfect build if
you want to get 144fps
whoa what's up dude Oh what's got that
dude oh that was close
me and I've got to say this is awesome
1080p60 absolutely perfect with this
build
ah run no oh look at this dude
[Applause]
whoa oh you see that boy pistol
come on pistol bursar I got me towel
come on man oh okay boom
minigun
[Applause]
oh you see that oh that's messed up man
come on oh come on dude this guy's just
hopping around in the water oh oh dude
oh so close oh my goodness oh man
gotcha so there you have it guys that
was a five hundred dollar budget gaming
PC in my opinion it's the perfect match
for fortnight at 1080p at 60 frames per
second so if you're interested in
building this PC definitely subscribe so
you don't miss out on our build guide
and if that video is already up we're
gonna have it right there in that button
and we're also gonna have the four
monitor comparison there as well so
thanks for watching guys and we'll see
you in the next video oh I just got that
dude did you see that